yeah hello and welcome to this video
which is the daily super blitz arena and
I'm somewhat later unfortunately yeah I
should join right yeah had a complete
misconception I was thinking that this
is starting in like 40 minutes and
instead it's like on already for almost
20 minutes yeah anyway I'm happy to be
back and do a video on my channel I've
put on vacation and back now for young
for some days um I couldn't do anything
back in my vacation at the end there was
simply no internet why somehow I had to
play played tournament right in Bavaria
and there was no simply no time to do a
video anyway I had some interesting
games
that's tournament so maybe I will do
something on those games let's cancel
hear me young pin him yeah this is
three-minute chess yeah after I have to
be somewhat quick can I go c5 quickly
that would be really nice no but maybe
here it my pin here this pin is annoying
and g4 it's not such a simple choice he
goes for it however okay maybe take here
and then Bishop g6 I didn't know what to
take but anyway let's do this if okay I
don't want to blunder the bishop one
thing is it's important I have got this
bishop
on b6 and this is a little bit off him
it's a bit off side the good thing is
said somehow yeah he's got this weakened
kingside if he wouldn't wouldn't have
that I think I would be but skeptical
about my chances but this way I think I
can get counterplay him yeah
102 97th place this is far behind
I hope the technical society is working
at least yeah this is something that I
had on the rate of it I simply cannot
believe that this is all that grade for
white my King position shall be the
better one
it's an amazingly bad poor information
okay now probably good back here because
he has no way to cover the spawn at
least I don't see any way to do it
Mott's ahead on the clock this is quite
good I should get some water and tries
to trade stuff I think i'ma just capture
and capture here with the time advantage
I'm quite happy here and he's got
further weakness ourselves here on c3
and quitting this important pawn
okay I can check him here or here Queen
d8 is the thing this is actually a
little bit a little bit annoying I think
I'll check first okay
and now queen chief um I can check here
King up King e7 and he can capture I can
capture e3 so it should be okay yeah
Queen trade the a pawn will win and also
yeah I think yeah I'm coming up and now
there's no Chuck and the Queen trade
which will win comfortably I have the f1
yep so yeah I'm of course quite behind
but three three minutes you can get in
many games if you get paired quickly and
maybe win the odd quick game I can
observe some games this is somehow
getting in fashion this Knight f6 Queen
e2 stuff 25 is a heads of a cheeky
trying to trade everything's super
quickly
[Music]
yeah but the queen is losing quite some
time
yeah maybe here I can go to if for me I
have to check it on the Queen yeah I
have to cover the bishop but only for my
queen is say I'm perfectly safe and h5
is not a move that helps a memory
castling short is not as easy as it was
now taking is good for Wyatt this is a
little bit debatable because of the
because of the berserk in situation
position is really very good takes
Knight xf7 is heavily under pressure
[Music]
if he calls 95 no even just taking leads
to a huge advantage yeah I think I would
do it but just that with the working
time things are not that easy what
you're going into a lost King appointing
it really should be losing we see four
come on mmm okay this first maybe this
should be maybe the cleanest and I have
one I have one minute this is this is
quite nice and I'm not super far behind
on the clock how do I do it this way
mm could have chicken twice but then so
takes takes king d3 has to go back in 6
hmm yeah I can always go to d5 so it
should should be enough I'll just take
it right okay so then you work down 88th
place get closer
yeah not so nice I didn't really want to
do this late join thing but I just I
don't know I should learn to read the
clock do everything it is at 8:00 8:00
in the evening but it was at 7:00 I get
a car Owen gala against Blue Girl start
with this
we should be something that looks a
little bit odd really looks more like a
square for one night t6 it looks very
very weak check wait for a moment and
see how black proceeds ahead looks
pretty terrible cannot take okay so
young get more pieces in quindi eight
meters the threat and now Knight f6 it's
not quite working but close we should be
five now what so in - I can almost
pre-move that okay take this the full
rook is good with chick again the check
and mate
so getting closer I don't know um who's
leading I don't really care so much
who's leading to be honest I mean the
points yeah but again been play game of
the game and see what happens do not ha
- okay
that's my match against so it seems
castles first okay yeah I have to cancel
first stupid yeah anyway it's hopefully
not and it's a crappy five he could have
played you five this is still some
reasonably normal position not perfect
of course but really canceling long
against the bank oh wow I mean okay we
have a cuz they have the Queen's trade
and it still looks pretty suicidal kind
of shocked to be honest but this happens
I could have taken maybe already only
four but this is not a bad move maybe
yeah keep it simple threaten this and
don't be too so grabbing some stuff
didn't berserk so it's a there's no real
hectic endures
if I was hanging and / - I mean no I
don't think you can cancel long against
the Banco
at least not in this structure there's
the hotline where it might work but not
that easy so I'm close to the top 10
looks like reasonable [ __ ] auction
I'm not really attacking this there's
opinion work in progress
yeah I don't know if this is good but
with the buzzer king after be able to
quicken that's probably it's so great we
should have form okay this is nice this
is nice for black okay
just playing for the pawn structure
which is pretty terrible okay so I think
I'll take this helps them a little bit
structurally but went with a tree down
and lost king upon endings all of the
time it's kind of remarkable here you
can actually play for a second before
passing here and the passage as well
some would get I will get to he simply
cannot stop an aged pawn and a pawn that
won't work
yeah I know okay seven plays sums are
six points behind it doesn't look all
that bad
I hope the whole technical side works
actually this is the first of it yeah
I'm doing
after being back home age three this is
preparing a forum I don't know if I need
to prepare it in a situation like that
but hmm now you can even do this free up
the four square F six really Wow
[Music]
hmm very interesting I can't do this
maybe just to gain more space and ask
him about the future of this night hmm
not so not so clear this thing you can
also play Bishop e6 maybe and go for the
light squares which are slightly
weakened here maybe so I've gained all
the spacing but it should be six I think
you should do this now mmm mmm five is
not possible with the game I still think
I should be okay with the but those
pieces not being that great huh I don't
I didn't think about that which was
actually quite bad I should have thought
about it mmm oh this is this is pretty
awful for him I've completely I
completely missed that before was
possible no my nights are really really
badly placed that's not good
should've just played a you have just
played a three
I don't want to take you know I don't
want to take I straightening to check
here Onoda for now I'm blundering d4
with the friggin check mmm doesn't see
and maybe next smooth
I couldn't cover it I mean a g5 is also
porn porn where it doesn't see it simply
I really miss played dad I'm lucky that
he didn't take you for really it would
have been almost would have been game
over stead he's doing something really
really funky why does that work I don't
get it
maybe it does work with I can just take
everything yeah my King position is
pretty bad so H it could work in some
way but I don't see it at the moment
okay so he allows me to trade it
straight and now what these squares are
all covered he one then would not be
covered I should probably bring this bad
for wiki tool now what is he going to do
one to be wanna meet
yeah seven seconds that's not so great
that was lucky
that's really lucky yeah I mean I just -
it just didn't really play three yeah
just stop before okay but it Sam I'm
still I'm in hunting for this tournament
oh my god okay maybe I can survive it it
doesn't look so scary white is really
really trying to trade down everything
really we said all that promising quit
b3 maybe yeah it's probably equal to
simply equal dispersion you know who he
will I have just blown to bits out
anyway okay if he takes it I get B - so
it's not it's not fatal
and then why does a particular K here
with everything probably just deform ya
know in this oh really it's a really
really surprising way to play it
he very basically deliberately creates a
weakness and then therefore I mean
you're not checkmating me him it can
probably just defend III it's very
unlikely that this is rock t5m should be
played
- this is extremely equal
still not offering you draw I mean you
never know huh this is a drawing if I if
I trade he's got the worst pawn
structure of it hmm not sure that you
needed to allow the ad but of course it
shouldn't matter all that much okay so I
will win a pawn but this is maybe this
is getting somewhat interesting it's not
so easy to defend before here because
I'm so active and of course I'm
threatening will create to check as well
I am losing both coins
yep and still just fourth place yeah
here's smokeless is winning every single
game as well him and he started to bit
earlier simply Jim they win every single
game
I should be paired against that would
help I came yeah FB what are you doing
home business cannot work come on
so you're why does that work he's giving
me this pawn and I can also just develop
like that I was probably pretty stupid
yeah Bishop c4
you know he is attacking this for real
okay it's still not bad stop like he did
was just so terrible that he shouldn't
even be there it's a completely
unplayable opening I'm a pawn up and he
has a hard time to develop I think you
should probably go d6 and just play a
pawn down for but you have to you have
to you have to develop the bishop
somehow cannot not sure if this was the
right way to proceed him that I'm not
sure about at all but okay it also could
help if he just resigned stop a stuff
but yeah if you want to catch up this is
always super annoying
okay so one point behind surprised
actually 150 points a my rating is
pretty bad zero zero zero okay there are
P six is kind of unnecessary but I mean
it's playable but we don't have to do
this set up and it's okay it's okay from
the trade night coming to t5 but
currently not possible and now he aims
to go 95 but I can take it by 97
shouldn't be bad Bishop one g7 is not
great
maybe I can try some Bishop h6 business
Bishop h6 okay 95 I can take it's not a
problem
so yeah I can trade this down let's see
if I can get night against this Bishop
alright still it's equal it's probably
just equal
that's a good move okay it probably
doesn't do much all right coming to say
five is a little bit annoying this one
is coming to just six me I should have
taken actually hmm okay but it's not a
big deal take 9 f 7 I can also go c6 b5
this is the main way to play this kind
of thing try to get a passer before I
take twice play night at 6 and reading a
pawn and a 4 is a person he has problems
to move his PCC for is always under
attack twice by the Knights and now he
is giving me this pawn
I think I still sober take take take hmm
hmm and I just saying I can take care of
them Kim take on they on take there's
always great income tree takes III what
I was trying to say even though I just
see that my night doesn't have all that
many squares if he plays King before him
okay have to grab this a pawn and
potentially H pawn is always difficult
to handle and I shall be winning it's a
bit much
those pawns
I don't don't strictly need to play
through what I resigned okay I was
thinking what happens here I thought I
lost one time first that groups didn't
die watch can do better against left
line gambit but I mean I was someone
completely shocked yeah I mean it was
almost a pre move that's what I was
trying to say yeah sometimes this stuff
does work but I cannot believe that this
works here no I'm the piece up
you know and this is very solidly place
there hmm
I cannot care so short it seems I'm a
king my king
yeah okay I took 1f to write yet I am
still want to cancel
it's fairly oops very simple technically
some it's no huge danger of screwing you
down what did you actually play King
behind again
I had discoveries oops
should've played some of the discoveries
okay yeah I've got them I've gotten the
lead now with 30 minutes left in this
event hmm I thought those daily arenas
would be I would have more I read a
players but it doesn't seem to be the
case the knight f6 they are remarkably
yeah I thought it makes sense to weaken
his king position there I'd lost
somewhat dangerous in fact for black I
wants to play the Queen to g4 yes trying
to try to trade me so I can't go Queen
h2 I mean
okay so I would love to sacrifice but
just add work
take takes Knight takes Queen g6 Bishop
d3 adds totally totally devastating I
think maybe hmm maybe if he goes like
rook f5 maybe I'm not actually winning
immediately here I mean I have the
chicken night h7 doesn't do much Knight
c7 maybe I can also cancel long maybe
canceling bone wait for more here
sometimes it helps I just wait for a
move check here I don't see a maid I'm
not in terrible shape material wise so I
don't have to win like by checkmate
quickly at least I think it's this is
the case I came now get this that this
is not hanging with check so Queen c7
gets an option it gets an option is
probably pretty terrible language
becomes an option on em so what did you
take some squares I don't see I don't
see a direct winner but again
material-wise is not so bad
Chappell six
[Music]
mmm be should Bishop
TX I have a key 5 which is mostly I
think it's reading stuff to be honest
yeah I wasn't good it wasn't all that
great never that's still winning I can
take h7 or I have various tactics kingi
aids I can take and go rook g8 being an
exchange up at the end it's still
completely winning I'm King f8 I can
take on f6 so I check on age 7
I would take this be the exchange up
okay
yes malice is not winning every single
game so I'm getting a small lead now by
8 points if not yet lost the game even
though one game was completely
completely terrible okay any loss do
something funny just playing it like it
was an English opening since it's
possible it's touch doesn't feel
completely off
in white white setup he is extremely
extremely slow so what I what I'm doing
is maybe a little bit fishy but I don't
think it's entirely lost or anything and
he's so passive that it probably is
somewhat playable and now the H file
open mm-hmm
Jim don't know 94 something is just
pretty much an empty threat and I don't
quite know maybe you should just yeah
I'm like this and I get down I'm on the
H file but I'm not yet threatening much
so how do I do it I need a night here on
age three or so I would be good maybe
like this I mean a four
really that looks very slow
b5 yeah I'm just going for a 95 and
night h3 so we is reacting to this idea
yeah ticking baby yep
yeah she takes you there's a pin in
effect um do I do I need to cover the
night problem October is wrong move it
that's what I'm trying to say hmm you
don't have to do it yeah you can take a
six this is actually a little bit find a
little bit off-putting is threatening to
take on b7 hmm I mean the scheme
position is still shaking but I doubt
that after taking on a six that I can
just allow allow him to caption I'm
quite no I mean I can do something I
know c6 also when he takes I take sounds
like I were entering pre-move know that
that I have a hard time to believe it's
a tech tech g3 e3 and everything it felt
somewhat slow
oops not that this is necessarily
terrible and I didn't think about this
of this move at all I mean not at all
not a single second but maybe I mean
he's putting it on the edge phone okay
and just recognize that I will probably
win on time this is just kind of stuff
h5 g5 in a few minute game this is
extremely awkward to defend yeah 12
points yeah looks like I'm going to do
it alright so just see that the camera
is rare anyhow on the dark side I have
my lights on but maybe the additional
lights would have helped
dynamites 1964 okay so he's saying
please check meet me on the edge from
yeah this is what he's saying okay
probably I cannot checkmate him on the
edge found all that quickly so how to do
this I need to the same Center is
somewhat somewhat shaky f6 I think I
probably need to pawn yeah
not going to be able to check me to know
anything I'm just trying to take this
back and have a good position with the
better bishop oh okay interesting take
take take
hmm yeah this is this this night sorry
Queen h4 at the end so I have to secure
my king first
okay here I'm still entertaining some
ideas of mating image for each five I
see going with f6 maybe that could be an
idea actually let's play for f6 all
right this is what he wants to do I did
not did not think about this at all hmm
that's a bit awkward I did definitely
didn't want to trade those really really
awkward hmm and I'm wondering g4 oh my
god mmm that's a bad game pretty it's
really bad he against this is horrible
opening with e6g cigs and so on
oh my god nice it's basically lost here
yeah and also it's so easy it's a
problem
yeah maybe I mean it still s to play the
odds
okay I've gotten this pawn and it is
support that he could have defended it's
not like that angling for Queen d3 not
even sure if this is good to be honest
but I don't think it's you're taking is
great I mean I have the potential
outside passim so maybe I can harass his
Queen now didn't see that one coming
okay my time is not great is this
important
probably very naive face he doesn't want
to win on position he just wants to
shuffle stuff and try to win on time
problem before I don't know it doesn't
help
I went to take with the pawn
kreeya Mitch what this is - almost
LaPierre thunder what is most what is a
garnish pian what I was seeing as I
didn't want to play this was really
unintended move he's taking this oh come
on
yeah take the point now I can never
calculate with any pre move anyway so
that was extremely unnecessary to lose
this game and now I'm playing in second
place this is funny but at least I know
what I win this then it's over I place
the same this place the same nonsense
again
that's really cool amazing like it's a
pond down and with the worst position
yeah what is that I play it twice now
it's even worse yeah because you will
have a bad bad pawn structure on top of
it
okay I need good tech I need to play
good technical moves but objectively
speaking what it's winning it was
winning anyway even though he gives me
annoyed okay hmm
I'm always able to screw screw things up
like this I don't see don't see this
Here I am
the Queen has no squares I probably had
something easier but a piece up is good
enough I say a way to checkmate him it
looks like there should be a way
almost checkmate didn't find a flaw made
but this is writer king f4 and every
window still continue this stuff I mean
is very coolly placed two times and
opening justice losses by force may
basically in the opening a really really
interesting
I mean at least the second time you can
play something where you're not lost
immediately okay so six points I can so
um give this away I've seen it happen
that all of a sudden somebody wins wins
wins and maybe it's a coup - yeah it's
got a streak okay so let's see what do I
play against this castles f4 it's not
bad
probably f4 hmm yes that a good pawn on
e4 is that a Buckner some interesting
interesting question g4 is probably a
bit much even though that aside looks
dangerous to be honest it doesn't even
react to it okay so I'll gain the utmost
space him he wants to trade the bishop
he on f1 well not not a big deal
[Music]
hmm doesn't take what no would be
surprising
it doesn't take indeed yeah I mean I
will try I almost have to take I can go
d5 actually let's do this
I mean I'm probably quick on the edge
file here okay come on here it's not yet
okay this I'm king of seven okay I can
start with this hmm there is a direct
window amazingly doesn't look like a win
okay that looks dangerous now
I mean I'm threatening now check and the
CAPTCHA doesn't that win somehow I
cannot believe it
okay let's let's just take check I don't
there's no window
really hmm rook to h6 maybe also I know
I don't
it's quite remarkable doesn't threaten
me much actually no t-taking years is
lame it's really lame hmm
I probably simply cannot chick made him
on the edge phone after maybe occupy the
D fall and see if I can do something
from here
Gyan checking here it's probably not
doing that much good I know I can go
here for rooty seven maybe and I'm
looking at g6
yeah which is seven now is a is a big
threat maybe you can go lucky six that
is a temple when they move December next
mmm but that doesn't help much I can go
on the eighth-ranked though and go from
here rook d7
okay it was tough I mean it's still not
not completely over but I wasn't really
getting getting much down that he cannot
defend okay that was important so just
four point four points that it's crazy
really closest is still I've lost a
one-game admittedly in a pretty bad way
that way I mean no after some pretty
idiotic play but still doesn't feel like
I've done so much wrong and somehow this
is not not over this tournament
okay so here maybe but let's go for him
he's got this madness there yeah this
thing looks I should have gone a six
let's do this now before he goes 86
taking you three okay don't think
there's a discovery right with the night
at least not a decent one this one yeah
this is actually possible oops oops I
mean f7 is covered
g3 might hang okay this I did not really
have on the reader hmm it's not this is
also a little bit shake him
except I have covered still ahead at
least no 95 is coming that that will
help a if I can get the night into this
and I need the Queen I his King is wide
open but somehow my pieces are not
active he sees even to school come on
play
I need this game in the books
come on
doing this where I am playing as the
playing this a little bit lame I could
have taken c3 actually with an come on
two minutes something left I mean I will
get it in the books probably if I be mm
quick iam White's position still sucks I
mean no d4 is hanging I'm winning you
form what is I can see how can and what
didn't see that coming at all and it
doesn't work fortunately oh it wasn't a
good idea
Jesus
and what am I doing here I'm hating this
completely skewed training quits I do
this oh my god it's crazy it's really
really very crazy I can probably win
this on time but this is not the way to
do it it's unbelievable what did I do
here the two parts all of a sudden now
all of a sudden the friggin coupons I've
got two points for this nonsense yeah
what I did but if he if he wins this
game if he wins his game it's over what
is going on here I don't know maybe I'm
winning this tournament I'm such a [ __ ]
yeah what did I do in this final game
having all of a sudden his pawns were
promoting that was really really weird
yeah it was hot closer than it should
have been the way it was what's going on
most of the time but I caught it in the
books at the end okay I hope you enjoyed
the video it's been the first one after
quite lengthy break